good morning believe nation today's  message is believed over you Jake  Gyllenhaal TV someone said to me once  that like eight and I know that being my  mother being a screenwriter she's not  gonna agree with me on this but that you  know great movies have been made out of  mediocre scripts and not great movies  have been made out of great scripts you  know so there is something in that  process because there is up there is a  general kind of philosophy that you need  a great script which I agree with I  totally agree with but ultimately I  think you need an energy you need a  drive and a belief and what you're doing  and that that belief whatever that is  can change an entire film I can change  anything really